[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 nous sommes le
mercredi 15 juillet voici les titres de
l'actualité locale est les vacances
d'été battent le plein pour repartir
dans ce contexte allié au coronavirus
les franciliens privilégie des solutions
ou plus locales et notamment celle de
passer des séjours dans les campings du
département reportage à rambouillet elle
est depuis avril à la tête du site
renault de guyancourt hélène ta vie a
pris la direction du technocentre et de
tous les établissements d'ingénierie de
la marque au losange dans la région et
bilan de ses premiers mois en fonction
au micro de tv 78 et puis nous vous
emmènerons à croissy-sur-seine à la fin
de cette édition les enfants ont été
initiés aux arts du cirque au château
chan auriez un stage initié par
alexandra bouglione mais avant de
développer ses titres l'hommage de la
patrouille de france rendue au personnel
du monde hospitalier qui a été très
engagé lors de la crise sanitaire et les
avions de la paf ont survolé aujourd'hui
l'hôpital andré mignot du chesnay
rocancourt établissements
particulièrement impliqué dans les
yvelines
elle est fumée colorée ont même été
libérée elle les soignants ont assisté à
la scène très brève depuis le toit du
centre hospitalier est la patrouille de
france va poursuivre son tour des
hôpitaux dans la région mais aussi en
bourgogne franche comté dans le grand
test et en paca et dans l'actualité de
la politique aussi on l'a appris à la
mi-journée philippe benassaya et othman
nassr ou partiront rassemblés pour
l'élection législative partielle dans la
11e circonscription des yvelines scrutin
prévu à l'automne et rendu nécessaires
pour rappel après la démission de la
députée nadia est devenu ministre
délégué à la ville le maire de bois
d'arcy et le premier vice président de
la région ile-de-france avaient fait
part de leurs intentions respectives de
se porter candidat ils sont finalement
parvenus à un accord pour garantir
l'unité de la droite yvelinoise philippe
benassaya sera titulaire othman nassr ou
son suppléant est la commission
nationale d'investiture du parti les
républicains se prononcera elle 22
juillet prochain elle udi pourrait
également apporter son soutien elle les
vacanciers ont pu profiter d'un long
week-end avec cette fête nationale du 14
y ait certains d'opter pour un séjour
nature dans ce camping de rambouillet
qui a rouvert ses portes le 18 juin
cette année le public est
essentiellement franciliens et pour
l'accueillir le site respecte un
protocole sanitaire strictes notamment
au niveau de la piscine naturelle
reportage de mathilde et demi et hugo
kitson la route pour arriver jusqu'à ce
camping situé au coeur de la forêt de
rambouillet n'a pas été longue
la plupart des vacanciers viennent d'île
de france et on choisit les yvelines
pour se dépayser
c'est un peu un hasard on
je suis ici avec cinq enfants mais qui
sont pas toutes et tous ses biens et ses
enfants devaient aller à une colonie de
vacances en bord de la mer qui a été
annulé à cause du comité on voulait
faire des vacances en départ à pied
donc en fait là on a une semaine de la
course départ de j fouet jusqu'à
rambouillet et on revient à gif donc
avec des étapes dans les gîtes bas au
camping sur ce site
150 emplacements sont à disposition pour
recevoir des camping cars ou des
voyageurs entente et 75 hébergements
atypiques sont proposés aux vacanciers
pour le moment depuis qu'on a réouvert
donc le 18 juin
on rencontre un public essentiellement
franciliens ils sont venus en masse dès
l'ouverture est là depuis une semaine on
revoit un peu une population étrangère
en recrudescence
pour ce couple d'australiens l'arrêt
dans la forêt de rambouillet était
primordial pour profiter de la nature
pendant leur voyage en france c'est
magnifique
toute la forêt c'est vraiment sympa et
on a emprunté beaucoup de sentiers pour
le vélo c'était très beau et bien
entretenus c'était agréable de sortir de
la route et d'aller en forêt pour
accueillir à nouveau les vacanciers le
camping a dû se plier à des règles
sanitaires strictes surtout pour leurs
piscines naturelles qui n'est pas
traitée au chlore et avec les protocoles
d'hygiène aussi inhérents c'est à dire
le gel hydroalcoolique avant d'entrer
dans l'espace piscine une petite
fermeture le midi pour pouvoir
désinfecter la plage puisque une piscine
naturelle ne se nettoie pas de manière
identique à une piscine chlorée pour ce
camping qui n'est pas encore complet les
réservations arrivent au compte gouttes
avec la crise sanitaire les français se
destine à partir près de chez eux
de quoi découvrir ou redécouvrir le
département des yvelines
elles ont été reporté de trois semaines
les soldes d'été ont démarré aujourd'hui
c'est jusqu'au 11 août est l'occasion
pour les commerçants d'écouler leurs
stocks après une saison particulièrement
difficile selon l'insee le volume des
ventes a même baissé de 45 % dans le
commerce de détail non alimentaire entre
avril 2019 et avril 2020 pour endiguer
ce phénomène beaucoup de boutiques
pas attendu les soldes cette année ont
proposé très vite des ventes privées des
promotions des l'annnonce du
déconfinement elle a pris officiellement
ses fonctions le 1er avril dernier
hélène favier la nouvelle directrice des
établissements d'ingénierie du groupe
renault en ile de france
une fonction qui la place de fête à la
tête du technocentre à guyancourt et
gestion de la crise sanitaire rénovation
du site ou encore regard sur les défis
actuels de l'automobile et nicolas
landry a pu l'interroger mais quel
ennemi d'euros aux moyens techniques et
l'incendié bonjour bonjour vous êtes la
nouvelle directrice des établissements
du groupe renault en ile de france
merci de nous recevoir ici au
technocentre de guyancourt
le premier site de recherche et
développement automobile en europe dont
vous avez de fait la direction
vous êtes en poste depuis le 1er avril
2020 pourquoi avez vous accepté cette
fonction
alors effectivement je suis directrice
établissements d'île de france de
renault c'est qu'ils comptent en fait
seize mille collaborateurs
c'est une grande responsabilité et pas
trop d'établissements c'est aussi
partager la vision d'entreprise
l'accompagné notamment par le dialogue
social
et c'est vraiment permettre à tous les
collaborateurs de donner le meilleur
d'eux-mêmes pour atteindre les objectifs
de l'entreprise
ici à onze mille salariés quelle
orientation vous souhaitez donner à
votre direction
alors en fait qu'est-ce que c'est
finalement le rôle d'un patron
d'établissement
c'est à la fois de garantir je dirais la
conformité réglementaire d'assurer la
protection des données d'assurer la
sécurité des collaborateurs
c'est aussi de donner les meilleures
conditions de travail possibles à nos
salariés
par exemple dans le cadre de la gestion
de la crise kobe 19
c'est ce qu'on a fait j'ai mis en place
tout le protocole sanitaire et puis
c'est également être ambassadeur de
l'entreprise et travailler à l'extérieur
avec les acteurs socio économiques qui
nous entoure et enfin c'est aussi gérer
les crises
comme je disais à plus récentes et ça en
fait deux
j'ai commis 19 quelle orientation vous
allez donner justement par rapport à la
gestion de cette crise vous avez des
exemples à nous donner alors ce qu'on a
fait c'est qu'il ya un protocole qui a
été établi dans l'entreprise pour tout
le groupe et non la adapté en fait au
technocentre donc est ce qu'on a fait on
a voulu préserver la sécurité donc on a
demandé par exemple le port obligatoire
du masque chirurgical sur site
on a également mis en conformité tous
nos systèmes de climatisation
la distanciation sociale on a réorganisé
totalement la restauration ton à la fois
permettre aux gens de se restaurer
également de respecter le protocole
sanitaire
et puisqu'on a fait aussi c'est qu'on a
optimisé l'utilisation du télétravail
autant qu'en fait on organise des
retours sur site et par rotation de
manière à avoir toujours maximum 30 %
des collaborateurs sur site qui puisse
travailler parce que il ya des choses
qu'on ne peut pas faire non plus bien au
télétravail mais en même temps qu'on les
protège parce que c'est la santé qui
nous préoccupe au premier plan ici
l'activité c'est autour de l'innovation
dans le secteur automobile les défis du
monde de demain c'est le véhicule
autonome le véhicule électrique on voit
derrière nous le le véhicule électrique
du groupe renault la zoé
quel regard vous portez sur ces deux
sujets qui sont les principaux sujets de
préoccupation ici au technocentre
renault de guyancourt
alors effectivement on est dans
l'industrie automobile confronté à une
vraie rupture à une transition
écologique également et donc on a besoin
de nous adapter et c'est ici finalement
qu'on va concevoir des véhicules qui
vont nous permettre de respecter ces
défis de man renault a été précurseur
sur le véhicule électrique donc
effectivement vous par kenzo et voilà
qui fait beaucoup de ventes en france et
en europe et donc pour nous c'est
vraiment clé de continuer sur cette
lancée
après mon rôle moi je suis pas ingénieur
mon rôle c'est le rôle de patron
d'établissement aisément de permettre
que nos ingénieurs développent ici au
technocentre
ce qui nous permettra de faire face aux
défis de demain qu'est ce qui se passe
ici au technocentre autour de ces deux
défis l'un autour des cons soit
finalement les moteurs les moteurs qui
vont nous permettre donc les moteurs
électriques
la batterie la gestion de la batterie
on a également donc ici c'est un peu
connu mais un atelier de prototypage
en fait on a une usine ici au
technocentre qui nous permet de préparer
en fait les prototypes véhicule on a
également toute la recherche amont
notamment vous parlez du véhicule
autonome du véhicule connecté et c'est
ce qui nous permet de danse 8 développer
les véhicules dans le monde entier par
rapport à cette activité haute valeur
ajoutée qu on veut maintenir en france
un dossier dont vous avez dû vous saisir
aussi depuis votre prise de fonction
c'est le programme de rénovation du
technocentre le programme le tcr à la
fois sur le bâtiment existant mais aussi
la construction d'un nouveau bâtiment
comment vous êtes saisis de ce dossier
là alors on a évidemment repris ce
programme dans le cadre de de nos
contraintes financières qui ont été
évidemment aggravé par la crise qu'ovide
donc en fait l'importance en fait de ce
programme c'est la modernisation de nos
installations mais également la qualité
de vie au travail et les espaces bureaux
et une orientation vers plus de
collaboratif également vraiment pour
être à la page en fait en termes
d'implantation donc on est en train de
revoir ce programme pour permettre son
financement
revoir le schéma directeur en tenant
compte également de ce qui s'est passé
finalement d'une plus grande utilisation
du télétravail sans doute dans le futur
qui va nous amener à imaginer la
solution du travail de dollars vous êtes
sur un territoire c'est le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines deuxième pôle
économique d'ile-de-france beaucoup
d'acteurs autour autour de vous
notamment dans le secteur de
l'automobile des start up des pme des
deux pays
quel regard vous portez sur cet
écosystème que vous avez entre autour de
vous alors on a la chance alors déjà le
technocentre dans sa dans sa surface à
ses cadets mon gros comme la défense
donc on voit bien l'impact que cela peut
avoir et compris d'ailleurs en matière
d'environnement et ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose sur laquelle je m'engage
personnellement c'est également protéger
notre environnement mais également
vis-à-vis des citoyens autour de nous
c'est également à maintenir des
relations importantes avec tout
l'écosystème
puisqu'on peut comme vous le disiez
trouver des partenaires autour de nous
et à premières en premier lieu
évidemment la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec
laquelle mon prédécesseur avait beaucoup
de contacts et avec lesquels je vais
maintenir cette relation de proximité la
mairie de guyancourt bien sûr puisque
beaucoup de nos salariés peuvent être
également des habitants de villes
environnantes y compris guyancourt donc
c'est très important en fait de nourrir
ces travaux ces relations est partagée
en fait les possibles et développer
finalement un tissu économique qui pour
nous est important merci elle est alliée
terrien directrice des établissements
renault et directrice du technocentre
renault de guyancourt
mercredi jour de sortie au cinéma si
l'activité reprend doucement dans les
yvelines deux nouveaux films continuent
tout de même apparaître et les équipes
n'hésitent pas à venir à la rencontre du
public dimanche dernier les deux
réalisateurs de tout simplement noir
dans les salles depuis la semaine
dernière venait défendre leur long
métrage à l'ugc ciné-cité skywest le
reportage de mélanie poké le contexte
salon faire à repousser la sortie de
leur film mais pas la rencontre avec le
public
pas mal cette initiative deux dangereux
tout simplement noir raconte l'histoire
de jean pascal
un comédien qui voulons c'est une marche
composé uniquement d'hommes noirs
il est au coeur d'un mockumentaire en
documentaire fictifs on voulait vraiment
ancré le truc dans une réalité on
voulait que ça paraisse vrai quoi parce
que voilà le truc qu'on décrit les très
actuelle donc on dit documentaire permet
tait de
en faire quelque chose de plus réel le
film il un message assez universel c'est
une comédie qui essayent de voile a
décrypté pas mal de pas mal de choses et
comme le fond il est assez universel on
essaie juste de montrer que voilà il ya
il n'ya pas réellement de communauté le
fait d'être noir ne fait pas de nous une
communauté et être noir finalement
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
le projet pensé depuis 2015 rassemble un
grand nombre de célébrités
un parti pris plein d'autodérision qui
trouve un écho particulier en pleine
affaire georges floyd et adama traoré
j'avais déjà ses questionnements là et
le fait que voilà
avec les événements qui se sont passés
ça arrive au moment de la sortie ça veut
dire que c'est d'autant plus d'actualité
c'est un film nécessaire 80% qui est
écrit et et bien sûr quand on a des mecs
comme farhi jonathan cohen ramzy fabrice
éboué on est très preneur de tout ce
qu'ils peuvent nous donner en comédie
donc ouais c'est comme ça qu'on allait
chercher donc fallait laisser une part
d'improvisation
sortie le 8 juillet dernier le film est
premier du box office en france avec
plus de 180 mille entrées cette campagne
à présent lancé par la sncf hashtags est
pas loin en train est une opération pour
relancer le tourisme en ile-de-france
est l'idée permettre aux franciliens qui
ne partent pas en vacances de se rendre
à une série de destinations accessibles
depuis les gares de la région et des
escales pas de thématique à faire à pied
ou à vélo qui sont proposés sur le site
du transilien re découvrir le château de
versailles et ses environs flâner le
long de la seine ou encore aller se
balader en forêt c'est pas loin en train
se déroule tout l'été dans le château
chan aurier à croissy-sur-seine trapèze
et jonglage était au rendez-vous
alexandra boglione issu de la célèbre
famille du cirque proposait un stage
dans sa discipline pour les enfants de 4
à 13 ans
retour sur cette semaine de stage avec
manon varaldo âgés de 5 à 13 ans ses
enfants apprivoise le monde du cirque
équilibre sur le fil et chasse mais
aussi acrobaties sur la boule ou au sol
j'ai fait la bonde on a fait le clown a
fait laitière ficelles
on a fait la galipette des contorsions
et est au programme avec des noms pour
chaque figure
c'est amer ce stage est organisé par
alexandra bouglione issu d'une célèbre
famille de cirque traditionnel
elle fait découvrir aux enfants son
univers le stage de cirque
nous le proposons depuis sept ans
maintenant depuis 2013 c'est un stage
pluridisciplinaire de cirque
on a adapté évidemment le stage à ce
contexte si particulier et en même temps
ça nous a permis de travailler de faire
d'autres autre apprentissage d'autres
techniques en groupe peut-être plus
restreints dans l'atelier installé dans
l'auditorium municipal les tables sont
espacées pour respecter la distance d'un
mètre et un lot de crayon est attribué à
chaque enfant
ils oeuvrent sur un dessin réalisé par
henri de toulouse lautrec tiré de
l'album au cirque chevaux en liberté
nous ici l'objectif c'est plutôt 2
s'inscrit dans la complémentarité de
proposer une approche du cirque qui va
plus être axée sur sur l'art et
notamment l'histoire de l'art vingt
enfants participent à ces ateliers
encadrés notamment par vladik après une
carrière dont le cirque il a décidé
d'enseigner les enfants choisissez dans
votre tête
quelle quelle petite saynète vous voulez
faire bientôt quoi dans le cirque il ya
l'émotion il ya la prise de risques via
le dépassement de soi qu'est la
solidarité c'est vraiment une très bonne
école et des valeurs qui sont beaucoup
recherché
avec la vie moderne le coût de cette
semaine 180 euros par enfant prochains
stages durant les vacances de la
toussaint
et puis à vil prix une habitante de la
commune va participer au raid amazones
une compétition 100 % féminine avec des
épreuves de tir à l'arc de course à pied
ou encore de canoë pour réussir son
aventure qu'à me brunet enchaîne les
sessions de sports michael et demi
d'euros l'a suivi séances de tir à l'arc
aujourd'hui à villepreux pour camille
cette mère de deux enfants de 38 ans
veut se perfectionner pour participer en
fin d'année au raid des amazones cette
compétition 100 % féminine créée en 2001
réunira en décembre 270 femmes en
thaïlande avec au programme des épreuves
sportives
c'est un rêve déjà dans l'idée de se
dépasser un peu de vivre une aventure
épanouissante
enfin voilà sortir un petit peu notre
routine sa zone de confort c'est du
challenge
il ya l'aspect voyage qui est important
car il ne partira pas seul en asie la
ville procès ne partagera cette aventure
avec son amie emilie 33 ans résidant du
puy-de-dôme
on s'entend très bien après la distance
nous séparent quand même parce qu'amélie
elle vit à clermont ferrand
et puis moi j'ai été amené à emménager
en région parisienne mais on se connaît
depuis une quinzaine d'années maintenant
on est amis et voilà c'est l'entente
m'entendre parfaite pour réussir à
performer le jour j la ville prose il
veut associer cette entente parfaite un
programme sportif rigoureux elle peut
s'entraîner jusqu'à six fois par semaine
hier c'est un peu exceptionnel mais j'ai
fait un triathlon j'ai fait 72 flèches
de tir à l'arc j'ai fait 6 km 300 de
course à pied j'ai enchaîné avec 12 km
de vélo c'est assez exceptionnel pour
moi
malgré tout ce qui est important pour
s'entraîner pour se préparer à fred
c'est d'arriver à enchaîner des séances
de sport quotidiennement sur plusieurs
jours consécutifs avec ses entraînements
camille espère pouvoir tenir
physiquement sur les six jours de course
et pourquoi pas terminer le plus haut
possible ce raid avec sa coéquipière
un mot de boxe avant de vous allez c'est
ahmed el moussaoui s'est imposé ce week
end à düsseldorf en allemagne
le sportif originaire de la verrière a
remporté son combat contre sergei
woodson l allemand a abandonné à la
deuxième reprise l'yvelinois totalise
désormais 33 victoires trois défaites et
un nul
il espère se lancer d'ici la fin 2021
vers un titre mondial
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]